the only way these women are going to go
on the record is if they all jump
together
why is sexual harassment so pervasive
and so hard to address
let's interrogate the whole system
hi my name is jody cantor i'm an
investigative reporter for the new york
times
what have you got i was told that the
wrongdoing in hollywood is overwhelming
i don't want to be quoted
period understood
in your previous stories how did you
persuade women to tell you what had
happened to them
a case i made was i can't change what
happened to you in the past
but together we may be able to help
protect other people
[Music]
the truth
basically
what is it exactly that we're looking at
here these young women walked into what
they all had reason to believe were
business meetings
i can still see it the hotel room the
floor plan
he kept trying to touch me
i
asked him to leave me alone
instead they say he met them with
threats and sexual demands i was young
scared hi
we're from the new york times i believe
he used to work for harvey weinstein
people have tried to write this story
before he kills it every time harvey
adamantly denies any allegation of
result he played people he was a master
manipulator
will you give me just one chance to talk
to you are you sure that this isn't just
young women who want to sleep with a
movie producer to try to get ahead
this is bigger than weinstein this is
about the system protecting abusers
the women who receive these settlements
they can't speak out they'll be sued if
they do but if someone could speak
freely about the payouts
what payouts john
you have to imagine that every call you
make has been recorded and you're being
followed can you imagine how many
harveys there are out there you want to
get me killed
do you wish you hadn't signed up for
this story do you
no
the only way these women are gonna go on
the record is if they all jump together
we're all here harvey who
have you talked to
i have three daughters and i don't want
them to ever accept abuse or bullying
i'll go on the record
go right
it's time to write
this is all going to come up
i was silenced i want my voice back
you